- Slap 'em silly?
Oh!
(Kelsey laughs)
Am I gonna get in trouble for that?
All right, all right, all right.
You guys ripped me
enough, roasted me enough
on my previous Sims venture
but I really wanna create Bear,
I really wanna become a doctor
but clearly I need some help.
So I called on
(exhaling)
Kelsey Impicciche, bee boop!
- Hi!
- We finally made it!
This has been a long time coming
for you to officially tell me
how much I suck at Sims.
- In my opinion the game,
The Sims, can be played
however you want, there's no
wrong way to play The Sims
but some people disagree with me.
- Just know that I'm a
better doctor in real life
than I am in Sims, I
gotta put that out there.
(Kelsey laughs)
Here is my very strange character.
- Is this your home?
- Yeah, I'm loading my home.
- It's like three small buildings?
Okay.
It looks accurate.
- What do you think about that?
- Why aren't the rooms connected?
- How do you connect them?
- There's two options I can give to you,
number one, I can help you
put the rooms together,
number two, you can go on the gallery,
download a nice home
that someone else built
and then move on with your life.
That's what I do.
- Okay, I'm gonna do that
because this could be
the most frustrating thing
I've ever done in my life.
- You know what?
Building's not for everyone, if you wanna
just get to the game, my
suggestion is always just take
someone else's hard work and play with it.
- Capitalism at its finest!
What am I searching for?
- Yes!
You just search starter home,
pick one that is in your budget.
- There's no like baller home, oh you have
to have money for it.
- We could cheat you
money if you want money.
- What!
- But I don't know, are
you, do you want to cheat
in this game?
- I don't want to cheat yet, Kelsey.
One step at a time.
Let's just keep it simple,
I'll go with this basic
budget starter home.
(gasping)
Look at that little
ranch.
- There you go!
- Like, first of all, how
do I see what he's doing
inside this house, this creepy guy?
- On the right bar,
there's a little arrow.
Do you see the arrow down?
Click that down arrow.
- Ooh!
Oh!
Look what our guy's up to.
- He's taking a bath.
(alarming synthesizer)
- I'd like to begin my journey
in becoming a physician
because I think thus far
I've done a pretty poop job.
Number two, I would love
to make my dog, Bear.
- I can definitely help you
with one of those things.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
Let's give him a makeover!
I love giving makeovers!
- Okay.
Oh my God!
What, who dressed this guy?
- What a look!
- I can appreciate a set of pink pants,
I can appreciate some camo
but I don't appreciate
the mix of the two.
What do people wear to sleep?
- What do you wear to sleep?
- Probably this.
- Probably that?
Okay.
Heck yeah.
- I love how non-judgmental you are.
- I don't even wear that to sleep!
- This looks like it's a
Valentine's Day look though.
- That's adorable!
It's a matching set!
- What do people wear
to exercise nowadays?
- What do you wear?
- I wear like--
- Every outfit, you ask
like, what do people wear?
Like, do you just wear scrubs?
- I basically just wear scrubs, I mean.
What is that booty though?
- You're gonna go with jean shorts?
- Look at the booty, there's no booty.
He's kinda flat there.
- He built it all in the shoulder
and did none on the lower body
and honestly, a lot of guys do that.
(Kelsey laughs)
- This is simple, I can vibe with this.
Okay, so that's his like,
every day, that's his work,
that's his sport, his sleep is
funky but I can get with it.
Party, okay, I'm not gonna change that.
Beach, okay, I don't know
what that is, hot weather?
- Hot weather, so when it's hot outside
and that's when it's cold outside.
- Okay, we'll leave that
'cause we don't wanna
get too advanced here.
(upbeat music)
- It's time for work!
- I'm going to work.
Now this is where I need the most help,
kind of ironic 'cause I've
done this in real life.
(Kelsey laughs)
Whoa, why is there
a very scantily dressed lady here?
- Bella Goth has come to say hi.
- He said he was lonely, how
do I get him to talk to her?
- Oh well she's gone.
(Kelsey laughs)
In order to know what to do at work,
it's up in your left hand corner
and you have three tasks currently.
First task, swab a patient for a sample.
Second task, deliver food
to a patient on the exam bed
and third task, check your patient's eyes.
Those are your current three to-dos.
- But look, I clicked on
all four of these folks
and they've all been swabbed for samples.
- Very interesting,
well then in that case,
let's try to deliver food
maybe to one of them?
Seems like your co-workers came in early
and already worked with
all of these patients.
- Gunners!
They're always coming in
before me, doing all the work.
so I can never get the credit.
So let's see what's going
on with our fella here.
- What's her name?
What's her story?
Who is she?
Why is she at the hospital today?
- How do we find that out?
Let's click on her.
- Well hover over her.
- Her name is Molly Edmunds.
- And she's a child.
She's there alone, like
where is her parent?
- You cannot treat children in a hospital,
well in a hospital in an
emergency setting you can
but if it's a medical office,
I cannot treat children
without parental consent.
Unless she's there to talk
about sexually transmitted infections,
she happens to be an emancipated minor
or she wants to discuss
obviously, an abuse situation with parents
and stuff like that.
Just so you know, Kelsey,
I have to get you to sign
a HIPAA form here 'cause you're learning
some privileged patient information
and privileged patient
information is a protected asset.
- I will sign the hippo.
- The hippo, oh my God!
- It says successfully
calibrate an X-ray machine,
so why don't you go
over to an X-ray machine
and see if you can
successfully calibrate one?
- Which one do you think looks
most like an X-ray machine?
- You know, none of them
but if you had to guess
what you'd put a person in
to X-ray them in this game,
what would you guess?
- This thing.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Looks like you did
one of them, good job!
You did it!
- So this guy, I feel like
he's quite lazy and unmotivated
because he's always
chatting up other people,
doing stuff that has nothing to do
with what I'm telling him to do.
How do I boss him around more?
Like this is not what I asked him to do.
- Ooh so do you wanna
turn off his autonomy?
And not let him do anything
except what you tell him to do?
- Is that a thing?
- Yes.
- How do I turn off his autonomy?
(Mikhail laughs)
No more free will, sir!
Why is Sean Stout here,
totally interfering
with my patient care?
- I don't know, maybe
you should fight them.
- Is that thing?
- I mean, you could if
you wanted to in The Sims.
- Slap 'em silly?
Oh!
(Kelsey laughs)
Am I gonna get in trouble for that?
Look at all these people waiting,
this place is inefficient!
How do I do this research
health reports thing?
- Click on a computer.
Or don't, yeah, there you go.
- Okay, come on buddy, step it up.
Step it up, get there!
Wow, he's really walking weird.
- He needs to pee!
- Oh.
If the hunger drops all
the way down, does he die?
- Yes.
- No, really?
- He starves, he dies, yeah
and if all the bladder
goes all the way down,
he'll pee himself.
(error tone)
- What is this?
I did a terrible job today?
- It's just about efficiency
and quickness, you know?
You gotta be quick about it,
you gotta get all the tasks done.
- My guy's monkeying
around the whole time,
slapping co-workers, how is he
ever gonna expect to work up?
(upbeat music)
- All right, there you go, add a dog!
- Oh do they have all the breeds?
- Yes, so search your dog's breed first.
- Okay, newf....
Oh my God!
I thing this is a chocolate
Newf, would you say this is
a chocolate Newf?
- I've never seen a chocolate Newf.
- Okay, I'm gonna show
you a chocolate Newf.
- Oh he's so big!
His name's Chewy like Chewbacca.
He's a mini Goldendoodle, so
he's Golden Retriever, Poodle
but mostly like a mini Poodle.
- Bear is a casual 141 pounds.
- Bear weighs more than me!
- This is fun.
I think making the dog is more interesting
than actually me making myself.
Ooh he has a first name and last name!
He is Bear Varshavski.
- Than you're done.
(Mikhail clapping)
- We have a Bear!
How do I train Bear to become
a service dog in this game
or an emotional support animal?
- Oh, I don't know if
they have that exactly
but you can train Bear, for sure.
- I'm gonna offer him friendship.
(Mikhail gasps)
Level one pet training skill!
- You're a better pet
trainer than a doctor so far.
- Okay, okay, that's all right.
Now that Bear's created,
can anyone play with Bear in this game?
- Yeah, so if you want to upload
your Sim and your dog to the gallery,
anyone can download that,
just like you downloaded your house.
- If you guys get this to 100,000 likes,
Bear and me will officially
be in the gallery
and I wanna know what you
guys are doing with it.
- You might have to
search yourself sometime
and see if you're accurately
portrayed in The Sims gallery.
- Dude, I already exist in this game!
- Yeah!
(Kelsey laughs)
- That's so nice and they
kinda gave me cool outfits.
This guy's ripped, someone
gave me way too much credit.
Kelsey, I think you set me up quite well
to start becoming a doctor.
I know what I need to do,
I need to spend more time
actually being attentive to my tasks
on the top left hand corner.
I'm gonna make some
moolah in the hospital,
I'm gonna make sure my
guy has an empty bladder,
empty intestine, never hungry.
Kelsey, plug your stuff,
where can people watch you?
- You can find me
anywhere on the internet,
on YouTube, Instagram and
Twitch @KelseyDangerous
and if you like to
check out my Sims shows,
you can check those out
on Buzzfeed Multiplayer.
- Awesome, you're the bomb, Kelsey.
Thank you so much.
- Thanks, thanks for having me!
- We will be in touch, we're
definitely gonna figure out
something fun to do on your channel
'cause I think the
audience is gonna want it
after this video.
- The fact that you are
already willing to slap your co-worker,
means that we're gonna have a lot of fun.
(Kelsey laughs)
- Check this out where
teen boys try to explain
what a period is
or my hospital Minecraft review.
That's right, which one
are you clicking on?
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)